today we're going to be discussing deep
reinforcement learning which is actually
one of a combination of disciplines
between deep learning and the
long-standing community of reinforcement
learning which has been around for many
decades now in machine learning and at a
high level reinforcement learning
provides us with a set of mathematical
tools and methods for teaching agents
how to actually go from perceiving the
world which is the way we usually talk
about deep learning or machine learning
problems in the context of computer
vision perception to actually go beyond
this perception to actually act acting
in the world and figuring out how to
optimally act in that world and I'd like
to start by showing a rather short but
dramatic video of a trailer of the movie
based on the alpha ghost story which you
might have heard of just to give us an
introduction to the power of these
techniques go is the world's oldest
continuously played board game it is one
of the simplest and also most abstract
beats me a professional player it go is
a long-standing challenge of artificial
intelligence
[Music]
everything we've ever tried in AI just
falls over when you try the game of Go a
number of possible configurations of the
board is more than the number of atoms
in the universe
I'll forego found a way to learn how to
play go so far alphago has beaten every
challenge me giving it but we won't know
its true strength until we play somebody
who is at the top of the world like Lisa
doll I'm not like no other is about to
get underway in South Korea they said
all is to go what Roger Federer is to
tennis just the very thought of a
machine playing a human because
inherently intriguing the place is a
madhouse welcome to the deep mind
challenge for world is watching
can Lisa doll find alphago's weakness
whoa is there in fact a weakness the
game kind of turned on its axis right
now he's not confident thanks it's
developing into a very very dangerous
fight hold the phone Rena's left the
room in the end he used about the pride
I think something went wrong gasps man
thank you he's got a plan here these
ideas that are driving alphago are gonna
drive our future this is it folks so for
those of you interested that's actually
a movie that came out about a year or
two ago and it's available on Netflix
now it's a rather dramatic depiction of
the true story of alphago facing Lisa
Dole but it's an incredibly powerful
story at the same time because it really
shows the impact that this algorithm had
on the world and the press that it
received as a result and hopefully by
the end of this lecture you'll get a
sense of the way that this this
remarkable algorithm that Valve ago was
trained and kind of going beyond that
although will then give a lecture on
some of the new frontiers of deep
learning as well so let's start by
actually talking about some of the
classes of what we've seen in this
lecture so far and comparing and seeing
how reinforcement learning fits into
those classes so first of all supervised
learning is probably the most common
thing that we've been dealing with in
this class we're given data and labels
and we're trying to learn this
functional mapping to go from new data
to a new to
one of the existing labels in our
training set and for an example we can
do things like classification where I
give you an image of an apple and the
algorithm is tasked to determine that
this is indeed an apple unsupervised
learning is what we discussed yesterday
and this deals with the problem where
there's only data and no labels and
comparing our problem with the Apple
example here I give it another Apple and
it's able to learn that this thing is
like that other thing even though if it
doesn't know exactly that these are
apples but it's able to understand some
underlying structure about these two
objects now finally how does
reinforcement learning fit into this
paradigm reinforcement learning deals
with something that we call state action
pairs so it says pairs of both states in
the environment that an agent receives
as well as actions that it takes in that
environment to execute and observe new
States and the goal of reinforcement
learning as opposed to supervised or
unsupervised learning is to actually
maximize the future rewards that it
could see in any future time so to act
optimally in in this environment such I
can maximize all future rewards that it
sees and going back to the Apple example
if I show it this image of an apple the
agent might now respond in a
reinforcement learning setting by saying
I should eat that thing because I've
seen in the past that it helps me get
nutrition and it helps keep me alive so
again we don't know what this thing is
it's not a supervised learning problem
where we're explicitly telling you that
this is an apple with nutritional value
but it's learned over time that it gets
reward from eating this and that should
continue eating it in the future so our
focus today in this class will be on
reinforcement learning and seeing how we
can build algorithms to operate in this
state action or learning and perception
paradigm so I've defined a couple
concepts in that previous slide like an
agent and environment action rewards
that I didn't really define and I'd like
to now start by going through
simple example or a simple schematic
where I clearly define all of those
things so we can use them later in the
lecture and go into greater greater
levels of abstraction so the idea of
reinforcement learning deals with the
central component of reinforcement
learning deals with an agent so an agent
for example is like a drone that's
making a delivery it could be also Super
Mario that's trying to navigate a
videogame the algorithm is the agent and
in real life you are the agent okay so
you're trying to build an algorithm or a
machine learning work model that models
that agent and the agent takes actions
in some environment now the environment
is like I said the place where the agent
exists and it operates within it can
send actions to that environment an
action is simply just a possible move
that the agent can make in that
environment and your action is almost
self-explanatory but I should note that
the action that the agent executes at
time T here I'm Dino Nia's little a of T
can be chosen from usually a discrete
subset of possible actions which we'll
call capital a so in this first part of
the lecture I'll focus on discrete
action spaces where there's a limited
number of possible actions you can
imagine me telling it in a video game
for example that the agent can go either
left or right forwards or backwards pick
up the block put down the block these
are all possible actions that you could
take in that environment now upon taking
an action in the environment the agent
will then receive some observation back
from the environment these observations
actually define how the agent interacts
with the environment and it can include
things like how the state changes so an
example of a state is for example if
you're the agent the state is what you
see so it's the sensor inputs that you
obtain it's your vision it's your sound
your touch these are all parts of your
state and basically it's a concrete
situation that the agent
finds itself at any given time so when
it takes this action the environment
responds with a new state that the agent
is located and given that action and
finally the last part part of this
schematic is the reward that the
environment responds with given that
action so the reward is basically like a
feedback that measures the success or
failure of the given action taken in
that environment for example in a video
game when Mario touches a coin it gets
an eight it gets a reward from any given
state an agent sends an output in the
form of actions to the environment and
the environment returns the agents new
state and an associated reward with that
action rewards can be either immediate
where you take an action and you
immediately get a reward or they can be
delayed in the context of delayed
gratification where you may take an
action today that you may not benefit
until you may not benefit from until
tomorrow or the day after tomorrow or
even in some cases very long term into
the future so building on this concept
of rewards we can define this notion of
a total reward that the agent obtains at
any given time the total future reward
rather as just the sum of all rewards
from that time step into the future
so for example if we're starting at time
T we're looking at the reward that it
obtains at time T plus the time to
reward that obtains at time t + 1 +
roared at t + 2 and so on there's a
slight problem here and that's that if
you are going to infinity if this
summation is going to infinity so if
you're looking at infinite time horizons
with potentially infinite rewards this
term capital R of T could also go to
infinity and that's not a great property
of mathematical equations so what we do
is we introduce this notion of the
discounted reward that's essentially
where we discount future actions based
on this discounting factor gamma it's
just a number between zero and one where
we're placing more weight on rewards
obtained in the near-term future and
placing less weight on
it's placed in long term long term time
steps from the current state
so I guess before moving on any further
I want to make sure that everyone
understands all of these concepts
present in this schematic because we're
only going to be building on things from
this point on and using these using this
terminology to build higher and higher
levels of that extraction so is this all
clear to everyone yep go ahead the state
changes immediate so usually you take an
action and that's let's suppose in like
self-driving cars if you want to train
an agent to navigate in a self-driving
car world
you do it your action is a steering
wheel angle and the next state is the
next camera and put that that car sees
it does not need to be related to the
world so the rewards are basically just
a scalar number that come back with each
state but you could also imagine where
there are no rewards and at a given time
step you might not see a reward but you
might see a reward way into the future
so for example in in some games like for
example pong you can imagine you've
never get a reward until you either win
or lose the game if you win the game you
get a positive reward but if you lose
the game you get a negative reward and
all of the intermediate frames and
actions that you take never result in
any reward at all so now we're gonna
take this notion of an agent collecting
rewards in an environment and try to
define what we call a queue function
this is kind of a fundamental function
that's gonna be the building block of
one of the algorithms that we're gonna
use in reinforcement learning in the
first part of this lecture and just to
reiterate again this this equation which
you see on the top is the same equation
as before it's saying the total reward
that we can obtain from time T it's just
a summation of the discounted rewards in
the future ok and now we want to define
this dysfunction which we're going to
call the cue function and it's going to
take as input two things one is the
state and the action that the agent
wants to execute at that state and we
want that cue function to represent the
expected total discounted reward that it
could obtain in the future so now to
give an example of this let's assume
let's go back to the self-driving car
example your plate you're placing your
self-driving car on a position on the
road that's your state and you want to
know for any given action what is the
total amount of reward future reward
that that car can achieve by executing
that action of course some actions will
result in better Q values higher Q
values because you're going to obtain if
the road is straight obtaining a higher
Q value might occur if you are taking
actions corresponding to straight
steering bowl angles but if you try to
steer sharp to the right or sharp to the
left your Q
is going to sharply decrease on each end
because these are undesirable actions so
in a sense our Q value our Q function is
telling us for any given action that the
agent can make in a given state what is
the what is the expected reward that it
can obtain by executing that action okay
so the key part of this problem in
reinforcement learning is actually
learning this function this is the hard
thing so we want to learn this Q value
function so given a state and given an
input how can we compute that expected
return of reward but ultimately what we
need to actually act in the environment
is a new function that I haven't defined
it and that's called the policy function
so here we're calling PI of s the policy
and here the policy only takes as input
just the state so it doesn't care about
the action that the agent takes in fact
it wants to output the desired action
given any state so the agent obtains
some state it perceives the world and
ultimately you want your policy to
output the optimal action to take given
that state that's ultimately the goal of
reinforcement learning you want to see a
state and then know how to act in that
state now the question I want to pose
here is assuming we can learn this q
function is there a way that we can now
create or infer our policy function and
I hope it's a little obvious here that
the strategy we want to take is
essentially like we want to try all
possible actions that the agent can take
in that given state and just find the
maximum the one that results in the
maximum reward and the ones that results
in the maximum reward is just going to
be the one that has the maximum Q value
so what we're gonna define the policy
function here as it's just the Arg max
over all possible actions of that q
value function so what that means just
one more time is that we're gonna plug
in all possible actions given the state
into the Q value find the action that
results in the highest possible total
return in rewards
and that's going to be the action that
we take at that given state in deep
reinforcement learning there are two
main ways that we can try to learn
policy functions the first way is
actually by like I was alluding to
before trying to first learn the q-value
function so that's on the left hand side
so we try and learn this cue function
that goes from States and actions and
then use that to infer a deterministic
signal of which action to take given the
state that we're currently in using this
argument function our max function and
that's like what we just saw another
alternative approach that we'll discuss
later in the class is using what's
called as policy learning and here we
don't care about explicitly modeling the
cue function but instead we want to just
have our output of our model be the
policy that the agent should take so
here the model that we're creating is
not taking as input both the state and
the action it's only taking as input the
state and it's predicting a probability
distribution which is PI over all
possible actions probability
distributions sum up to one they have
some nice properties and then what we
can do is we can actually just sample an
action from that probability
distribution in order to act in that
state so like I said these are two
different approaches for reinforcement
learning two main approaches and the
first part of the class will focus on
value learning and then we'll come back
to policy learning as a more general
framework and more powerful framework
we'll see that actually this is what
alphago uses policy learning is what
alphago uses and that's kind of what
we'll end on and touch on how that works
so before we get there let's keep going
digger let's keep going deeper into the
Q function so here's an example game
that we'll consider this is the atari
breakout game and the way it works is
you're this agent you're this little
pedal on the bottom and you can either
choose to move left or right in the
world at any given frame and there is
this ball also in the world that's
coming either towards you or away from
you your job as the agent is to move
your
idle left and right to hit that ball and
reflect it so that you can try to knock
off a lot of these blocks on the top
part of the screen every time you hit a
block on the top part of the screen you
get a reward if you don't hit a block
you don't get a reward and if that ball
passes your pedal without you hitting it
you lose the game so your goal is to
keep hitting that ball back onto the top
of the board and breaking off as many as
many of these colored blocks as possible
each time getting a brand new reward and
the point I want to make here is that
understanding queue functions or
understanding optimal queue values is
actually a really tough problem and if I
show you two possible example states and
actions that an agent could take so for
example here's it makes a pedal with a
ball coming straight for the paddle down
the agent can choose to stay where it is
and basically just deflect that ball
straight back up that's one possible
state action pair another possible state
action pair is where the ball is coming
slightly at an angle towards the pedal
the paddle can move slightly to the
right hit that ball at an angle and just
barely just barely knick it and send it
ricocheting off into the screen and to
the side of the screen
rather now the question I have here is
as a human which action state action
pair do you think is more desirable to
be in in this game which of you think
it's a okay how about be interesting so
actually you guys are much smarter than
I anticipated or maybe you're just
looking at the notes because the correct
answer is B even in a slightly
stochastic setting let's suppose you
keep executing a and you keep hitting
off these blocks in the middle of the
screen you're kind of having a limited
approach because every block that you
knock off has to be this one that you
explicitly aim towards and hit so here's
an example of a policy executing
something like a and it's hitting a lot
of the blocks in the center of the
screen not really hitting things on the
side of the screen very often even
though it's not going directly
up and down it is targeting the center
more than the side okay now I want to
show you an alternative policy now it's
B that's explicitly trying to hit the
side of the paddle every time no matter
where the ball is is trying to move away
from the ball and then come back towards
it so it hits the side and just barely
hits the ball so I can send it
ricocheting off into the corner of the
screen and what you're gonna see is it's
gonna basically be trying to create
these gaps in the corner of the screen
so on both left and right side so that
the ball can get stuck in that gap and
then start killing off a whole bunch of
different blocks with one single action
so here's an example it's gonna be
trying to kill off those side blocks now
it's going for the left side and once it
breaks open now you can see it just
starts dominating the game because it's
ball is just getting stuck on that top
platform and it's able to succeed much
faster than the first than the first
agent in agent a so to me at least this
was not an intuitive action or an
intuitive Q value to learn and for me I
would have assumed that the safest
action to take was actually a but
through reinforcement learning we can
learn more optimal actions than what
might be immediately apparent to human
operators so now let's bring this back
to the context of deep learning and find
out how we can use deep learning to
actually model Q functions and estimate
Q functions using training data and we
can do this in one of two ways so the
primary way or the primary model that's
used is called a deep Q Network and this
is essentially like I said a model
that's trying to estimate a Q function
so in this first in this first model
that I'm showing here it takes as input
a state and a possible action that you
could execute at that state and the
output is just the Q value it's just a
scale or output and it's the neural
network is basically predicting what is
the estimated expected total reward that
it can obtain given the state and this
action then you want to train this
network using mean squared error to
produce the right answer given a lot of
training data at a high level that's
what's going on
the problem with this approach is that
if we want to use our policy now and we
want our agent to act in this world we
have to feed through the network a whole
bunch of different actions at every time
step to find the optimal queue value
right so we have to for every possible
action imagine we have a ton of actions
in the previous example it's simple
because we only have left and right as
possible actions but let's suppose we
have a ton of different actions for each
action we have to feed in the state and
that action compute the Q value do that
for all actions now we have a whole
bunch of Q values we take the maximum
and use that action to act okay that's
not great because it requires executing
this network in a forward pass a total
number of times that's equal to the
total number of actions that the agent
could take at that step another
alternative is slightly reaper amat
rising this problem still learning the Q
value but now we input just the state
and the network intrinsically will
compute the Q value for each of the
possible actions and since your action
space is fixed and reinforcement
learning in a lot of cases your output
of the network is also fixed which means
that it each time you input a state and
the network is basically outputting and
numbers where n is the dimensionality of
your action space where each output
corresponds to the Q value of executing
that action now this is great because it
means if we want to take an action given
a state we simply feed in our state to
the network it gives us back all these Q
values we pick the maximum Q value and
we use the wrote we use the action
associated to that maximum Q value in
both of these cases however we can
actually train using mean squared error
it's a fancy term a fancy version of
mean squared error that I'll just
quickly walk through so the right side
is the predicted Q value that's actually
the output of the neural network just to
reiterate this takes as input the state
and the action and this is what the
network predicts you then want to
minimize the error of that predicted Q
value compared to the true or the target
Q value
which in this case is on the right hand
side so the target Q value is what you
actually observed when you took that
action so when the agent takes an action
it gets a reward that you can just
record you store it in memory and you
can also record the discounted reward
that it receives in every action after
that so that's the target return that's
what you know it that's what you know
the agent obtained that's a reward that
they obtained given that action and you
can use that to now have a regression
problem over the predicted Q values and
basically over time using back
propagation it's just a normal
feed-forward network we can train this
loss function train this network
according to this loss function to make
our predicted Q value as close as
possible to our desired or target Q
values and just to show you some
exciting results so when this first came
out paper by deep mind showed that it
could work in the context of Atari games
and they wanted to present this general
deep Q network this just learning
through deep Q networks where they input
the state of the game on the left-hand
side pass it through a series of
convolutional layers followed by
nonlinear activation functions like
rellis and propagating this information
forward each at each time using
convolutional layer activation function
fully connected layer activation
function and then finally at the output
we have a list of n Q values where each
Q value corresponds to the possible
action that it could take and this is
the exact same picture as I gave you
before except now it's just for a
specific game in Atari and one of the
remarkable things that they showed was
that this is an incredibly flexible
algorithm because without changing
anything about this algorithm but just
deploying it in many different types of
games you can get this network to
perform above human level on a lot of
different tasks in Atari so Atari is
composed of a whole bunch of games which
you can see on the x-axis so each bar
here is a different game in Atari and
things to the left of this vertical bar
correspond to situations where the
deep Q Network was able to outperform
the level of a human operator in that
game
there are definitely situations in an
Atari where that the DQ network was not
able to outperform human level and
typically what was noticed by a lot of
researchers afterwards was that in
situations or in games where we don't
have a perfectly observable world where
if I give you a state you can observe
the like you can optimally observe the
correct action to take in that state not
all of these games are having that
property and that's a very nice property
to have so a lot of games have very
sparse rewards for example this this
game on the end montezuma's revenge is
notorious for having extremely sparse
rewards because it requires that the
agent go through a ladder go to a
different room and collect a key and
then use that key to turn the knob or
something like that and without randomly
exploring or possibly seeing that
sequence of states the agent would never
get exposed to those cue values it could
never learn that this was an optimal
action to take if it just randomly
explores the environment it's never
going to actually see that possible
action in that case it's never ever
going to get any context of what the
optimal action to take is in the context
of breakout which I was showing you
before where you have that paddle and
the ball hitting the paddle and you're
trying to break off all of these points
on the top this is an example of a game
where we have perfect information so if
we know the direction of the ball we
know the direction of what the position
of our paddle and we see all of the
points in the in the space we can
correctly predict with like we we have
an optimal solution at ma given state
given what we see of where to move the
paddle that kind of summarizes our topic
of Q learning and I want to end on some
of the downsides of Q learning it
surpasses human level performance on a
lot of simpler tasks but it also has
trouble dealing with complexity it also
can't handle action spaces which are
continuous so if you think back to the
way we defined the Q Network the deep Q
Network
we're outputting a
q-value for each possible action it
could take but imagine you're a
self-driving car and the actions that
you take are a continuous variable on
your steering wheel angle it's the angle
that the wheel should turn now you can't
use cue learning because it requires an
infinite number of outputs there are
tricks that you can get around this with
because you can just discretize your
action space into very small bins and
try to learn the Q value for each bin
but of course the question is well how
small do you want to make this the
smaller you make these bins the harder
learning becomes and just at its core
the vanilla Q learning algorithm that I
presented here is not well-suited for
continuous action spaces and on another
level they're not flexible to handle
stochastic policies because we're
basically sampling from this argument
function we have our Q function and we
just take the arc max to compute the
best action that we can execute at any
given time it does it means that we
can't actually learn when our when our
policies are stochastically computed so
when the next state is maybe not
deterministic but instead having some
random component to it as well right so
this is the point I mentioned about the
continuous action space being actually a
very important problem that might seem
kind of trivial to deal with by just
bending the solution bending the outputs
but this is actually a really big
problem in practice and to overcome this
we're gonna consider a new class of
reinforcement learning models called
policy gradient models for training
these algorithms so policy gradients is
a slightly different twist on Q learning
but at the foundation it's actually very
different so let's recall Q learning so
the deep Q network takes input the
states and predicts a Q value for each
possible action on the right hand side
now in policy gradients we're gonna do
something slightly different we're gonna
take us and put the state but now we're
gonna output a probability distribution
over all possible actions again we're
still considering the case of discrete
action spaces but we'll see how we can
easily extend the
in ways that we couldn't do with
q-learning to continuous action spaces
as well let's stick with discrete action
spaces for now just for simplicity so
here pie of alpha sorry PI of AI for all
I is just the probability that you
should execute action I given the state
that you see as an input and since this
is the probability distribution it means
that all of these outputs have to add up
to one we can do this using softmax
activation function and deep neural
networks it's just enforces that the
outputs are summing to one and again
just to reiterate this PI a given s is
the probability distribution of taking a
given action given the state that we
currently see and this is just
fundamentally different than what we
were doing before which was estimating a
Q value which is saying what is the
possible reward that I can obtain by
executing this action and then using the
maximum the Q value of maximum reward to
execute that action so now we're
directly learning the policy we're
directly saying what is the correct
action that I should take what is the
probability that that action is a 1
whereas the probability that that action
is a 2 and just execute the correct
action so in some sense it's skipping a
step from Q learning and Q learning you
learn the Q function use the Q function
to infer your policy and policy learning
you just learn your policy directly so
how do we train policy gradient learning
essentially the way it works is we run a
policy for a long time before we even
start training we run multiple episodes
or multiple rollouts
of that policy a roll out is basically
from start to end of a training session
so we can define a roll out as basically
from time 0 to time T where T is the end
of some definition of a episode in that
game so in the case of breakout capital
T would be the time at which the ball
passes the pad
you miss it so this is the time when the
episode ends and you miss the ball or
it's the time at which you kill all of
the points on the top and you have no
other points to kill so now the game is
over so you run your policy for a long
time and then you get the reward after
running that policy now in policy
gradients all you want to do is increase
the probability of actions that lead to
high rewards and decrease the
probability of actions that lead to low
rewards it sounds simple it is simple
let's just see how it's done by looking
at the gradient which is where this this
algorithm gets its name which is right
here so let's walk through this let's
walk through this algorithm a little
more detail so we do a roll out for an
episode given our policy so policy is
defined by the neural network
parametrized by the parameters theta we
sample a bunch of episodes from that
policy and each episode is basically
just a collection of state action and
reward pairs so we record all of those
into memory then when we're ready to
begin training all we do is compute this
gradient right here and that gradient is
the log likelihood of seeing a
particular action given the state
multiplied by the expected reward of
that action sorry excuse me that's the
expected discounted reward of that
action at that time so let's try and
parse what this means because this is
really the entire policy gradient
algorithm on this one line this is the
key line here so let's really try and
understand this line the green part is
simply the log likelihood of obtaining
or of outputting that action so let's
suppose our action was very desirable it
led to a good reward okay and that's
just defined by we do our roll out on
the top and we won the game at the end
so all of these policies all of these
actions should be enforced or reinforced
and in this case we did and on the
second line we did another episode which
resulted in a loss all of these Paul
should be discouraged in the future so
when things result in positive rewards
we multiply this is going to be a
positive number and we're going to try
and increase the log likelihood of
seeing those actions again in the future
so we want to tell the network
essentially to update your parameters
such that whatever you did that resulted
in a good reward is gonna happen again
in the future
and to even greater probability so let's
make sure that we definitely sample
those things again because we got good
rewards from them last time on the
converse side if R is is negative or if
it's zero if we didn't get any reward
from it we want to make sure that we
update our network now to change the
parameters and make sure that we
discourage any of the probabilities that
we output on the previous time so we
want to lower the log likelihood of
executing those actions that resulted in
negative rewards so now I'll talk a
little bit about the game of Go and how
we can use policy gradient learning
combined with some fancy tricks that
deepmind implemented in the game of
alphago in the algorithm alphago and i
think the core for those of you who
aren't familiar with the game of Go it's
an incredibly complex game with a
massive state space there are more
States than there are atoms in the
universe and that's in the full version
of the game where it's in 19 by 19 game
and the idea of go is that you have a
it's a two-player game black and white
and the motivation or the goal is that
you want to get more board territory
than your opponent the state here is
just the board of black and white cells
and the action that you want to execute
it's just a probability distribution
over each possible cell that you need to
put your next piece out that cell so you
can have a you can train a network like
we were defining before a policy based
net network which takes us input an
image of this board it's a 19 by 19
image where each pixel in that image
corresponds to a cell in the board and
the
part of that network is going to be a
probability distribution again it's a 19
by 19 probability distribution where
each cell is now the probability that
your next action should be placing a
token on that cell on the board right so
let's see how at a high level the
alphago algorithm works
they use a little trick here in the
beginning which is they start by
initializing their network by training
it on a bunch of experts from sorry
sorry they training it from a bunch of
human experts on playing the game of go
so they have humans play each other
these are usually professional or very
high quality high-level humans they
record all of that training data and
then they use that as input to train a
supervised learning problem on that
policy network so this again takes us
input in action sorry it excuse me it
takes us input the state of the board
and it tries to maximize the probability
of executing the action that the human
output or sorry executing the action
that the human executed okay so now this
first step here is focusing on building
a model using supervised learning to
imitate what the humans how the humans
played the game of go of course this is
not going to surpass any human level
performance because you're purely doing
imitation learning so the next step of
this algorithm is then to use that
network which you trained using
supervised learning and to pit it
against itself in games of self play so
you're gonna basically make two copies
of this network and play one network
against itself and use now reinforcement
learning to achieve superhuman
performance so now since its play
against itself and not it's not
receiving human input its able to
discover new possible actions that the
human may not have thought of that may
result in even higher reward than before
and finally the third step here is that
you want to build another network at
each time at each position on the board
so it takes now
the state of the board and tries to
learn the value function and that's
essentially very similar to the cue
function except now it's outputting one
output which is just the maximum Q
function so over all actions this this
value network is basically telling you
how good of a board state is this so
this gives us an intuition we're using
neural networks now to give us an
intuition as to what board states are
desirable what support states may result
in higher values or more probability of
winning and you might notice that this
is very closely related to the Q
function this is telling us like I said
at the core how desirable a given board
state is and basically just by looking
at the board state we want to determine
is this a good board state or a bad
sport state and the way that alphago
uses this is it then uses this value
network to understand which parts of the
game it should focus more on so if it's
at a particular state where it knows
that this is not a good state to be in
it knows that it shouldn't keep
executing trials down the state so it's
able to actually prune itself and have a
bit of a more intelligent algorithm of
learning by not executing all possible
actions at every time step but by kind
of building a smart tree of actions
based on this heuristic learned by
another network and the result is
alphago which in 2016 beat lee sedol
which is who's the top human player at
go and this was the first time that an
AI algorithm has beaten top human
performers in the game of go this was
really a groundbreaking moment it ties
us back to that trailer that we saw at
the beginning of class and finally just
to summarize some really exciting new
work from the same team that created
alphago now they've released a new model
called alpha zero which was published in
science about one month ago and it's a
general framework for learning self play
models of board games so they show it
being
to outperform top model-based approaches
and top human players in games of chess
shogi and alphago so it's actually able
to surpass the performance of alphago in
just 40 hours and now this network alpha
zero is called alpha zero because it
requires no prior knowledge of human
players it's learned entirely using
reinforcement learning and self play and
that's kind of the remarkable thinkers
that without using any prior information
at all now we've shown it's possible to
one learn the possible or learn the
likely sets of moves that human players
would make and then the really
interesting thing is that it then kind
of starts to discard those moves in
favor of even better moves that humans
never really thought of making and the
really interesting thing is if you
follow this this evolution of the
rewards going up in time if you stop it
at any intermediate time especially on
the early parts of so if you stop in the
early training parts like for example
right here and you look at the behavior
of these agents they behave similar to
top human players so they especially the
execute the actions that they execute in
the initial board states like right when
the game starts they behave very similar
to top human players but then as
training continues and the agent starts
to discover new and new more and more
different advanced ways of executors
starting the game it's actually able to
create new policies that humans never
even considered and now alpha zero is
being used as almost a learning
mechanism for top human performers on
these new policies that can improve
humans even more I think this is a
really powerful technique because it
shows reinforcement learning being used
not just to pit humans against machines
but also as a teaching mechanism for
humans to discover new ways to execute
optimal policies in some of these games
and even going beyond games the ultimate
goal of course is to create
reinforcement learning agents that can
act in the real world
robotic reinforcement learning agents
not just in simulated board games but in
the real world with humans and help us
learn in this world as well so that's
all for reinforcement learning happy to
take any questions or will hand it off
Dava for the new frontiers of deep
learning in the next part okay thank you
[Applause]